so you can perfect
[Music]
all right what's up everybody hope
you're having a good day
my name is dopaziola i am the host of
the dope as usual podcast
and this is episode three thank you guys
so much for joining us once again for
all the people on spotify
apple youtube whatever you're listening
to whatever you're watching from
we appreciate you so guys this is
episode three i'm super [ __ ] excited
this is the second solo episode
and just for future reference we'll be
doing solo episodes here and there but
they're not going to be the majority
we're mainly going to have guests guys i
want to get straight into this
i'm in a good [ __ ] mood today just
from me to you i'm in an awesome mood
today
um i usually got a bunch of [ __ ]
going on people [ __ ] with me but today
is great
today everything's just aligning i sold
my [ __ ] car finally last night i've
been paying
a thousand dollars a month for my backup
car that i don't want
because i'm done with it and my [ __ ]
dad finally came this morning and bought
it super stoked
he's giving it to my little sister and i
hate to put her on blast but
she got caught smoking weed in the
bathroom the other day at the [ __ ]
house like a dummy
so now she gets to stare at the car
until my dad feels that
she's allowed to drive it i'm so
happy i didn't live with my dad as a kid
man well
no i would have done more drugs i think
i would have got away with more
but still she's getting it my dad's an
actual dad now and like there's
repercussions and [ __ ]
so it's very it's [ __ ] hilarious to
me because i was smoking weed in the
bathroom at 15 too except i wasn't dumb
enough to leave ashes in the sink
like she did sorry to put that up my
little sister on blast
right away but that's what's on my mind
right now so yeah got rid of the car
super stoked my credit's going to go up
sell that [ __ ] back to
uh buy that full from carmax and we're
done
um besides that point uh push trees the
clothing company if you're a fan you
already know but if you're not we own a
clothing company called push trees
oh my god we just got our samples in
yesterday guys all high-end bags and i'm
i've never said this i'm completely not
disappointed
i am 100 excited i've never gone into a
manufacturing meeting
give me my stuff and i go you guys did
exactly what we said i mean they are
100 on top of it marty you saw the bags
i was astounded shocked shocked
dude i was astounded at the quality and
i was astounded that there wasn't a
whole back and forth you cursing them
right nothing it took two months for for
manufacturing time
and they actually sent me what i wanted
and what i ordered what i designed
couldn't be more [ __ ] happy guys um
also we got the biggest shipment of push
trees bongs we've ever gotten
i'm really excited for that last time we
sold out in nine [ __ ] minutes
which is
ridiculous and then i got deleted the
next
two minutes later so there's a give and
take but today it's all [ __ ] taken
it's from our end i am just happy i'm in
a good ass mood
we got some videos to go we got the
podcast going i'm [ __ ] hyped
um let's hop right into this guys i
don't i'm gonna tell you this now if you
know me i don't watch the [ __ ] news
i don't know who's who i have no idea
what's going on i don't know what the
stock market's going on
all the news i get is from [ __ ]
twitter i'm gonna be 100 honest and i
know a lot of you just went yup
because me too man i just look at
twitter and that's the only news i get
so apparently this is what i got today
jeff bezos the guy that owns amazon just
quit amazon
how the [ __ ] do you quit your own
company i don't get that he stepped down
as the ceo of amazon
i didn't know that was a real thing it's
like yo willy wonka no i [ __ ] quit
bro no i let it go i just
pay me and i quit how does that work
mark do you have any idea how
stepping down as a ceo of your own
company works that's the goal in my mind
oh of course we're like willy wonka hey
charlie you and your bitch-ass grandpa
your lazy-ass grandpa you just take over
my [ __ ]
move your whole [ __ ] family in that's
how that went yeah the whole point of
the business
is one day to have it be able to
function without you nobody stepped down
so what does that mean oh so he's got
somebody to replace him
i don't know he's it's probably some
legal thing surrounding a divorce
or him about to get cancer i mean for
those of you that aren't dumb like me
i mean for those of you that are dumb
like me and don't pay attention to the
news jeff bezos the richest man on the
[ __ ] planet until two days ago when
was the elon musk passed his ass up
which is pretty [ __ ] cool
i think that's awesome elon musk i feel
might be part alien
i think he's too smart i think that's in
fact yeah i think he's too smart to be a
person
just from me to you just for me
that's confirmed the way lebron and
michael jordan dunk i feel like nah
there's athleticism yeah there's
something else there's the monstars gene
from space jam in your ass because
there's no [ __ ] way these fools can
jump from the free-throw line
um i mean of course they can they're
huge but and everybody's like he's such
a [ __ ] idiot his rocket ship
crashed on mars again like yo his rocket
ship
made it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yo he's literally a rocket scientist
he's famous as [ __ ] nobody hates on him
everybody loves his ass
and he's kind of cool he's mad
interesting but see we talked about jeff
bezos boring actually we went straight
to elon musk
on how cool he is um that's all i know
all i know is he stepped down has
got a divorce yo the richest man in the
planet
got a divorce how much
pain that night that man went through
goes i just lost 50 billion
not even 50 i lost 50 billion
dollars it's the moment before that pain
when he was like and i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i don't [ __ ] care i mean that's
cool that's a
that's the goal man that's the goal to
be so rich go no take half of it i will
never
spend it that sounds awesome to me
that's [ __ ] cool dude
um i think it's [ __ ] cool but that's
the news i got
that's all the news i got i read a
[ __ ] little tiny article and go all
right
going on with my day that's all the news
i needed um but in news that i really
like
yo for all you football fans out there
what a [ __ ] era
ending how weird is it that drew brees
just retired
philip rivers just retired what
dude that make takes me back to like
chunky soup [ __ ] donovan mcnabb with
my grandma me chugging [ __ ] stunning
delights
that just reminds me of football man and
seeing
remember drew brees started off in san
diego
then philip rivers replaced his ass drew
brees went on to be the man
anyway philip rivers is still the
[ __ ] man and they both stop on the
same year
same day they both retired i think the
same day man i remember i saw
i saw drew brees uh play when he played
for purdue at notre dame
we were at notre dame and he was a big
deal then and i remember thinking
because at the pep rally
the mascot was like yeah he's like it's
gonna be sunny
and little to no breeze oh hell no
badass dude he was i'm pretty sure
purdue beat the [ __ ] out of notre dame
that day
i got to be honest man our era of
football growing up was the best era the
90s to 2000s was the coolest most
fun air for football we had [ __ ] the
dirty bird we had deion sanders doing
his [ __ ]
tara owens [ __ ] with the cowboys
steve young almost done with his career
oh [ __ ] randy moss dante culpepper
all these [ __ ] brian erlacker
man i wanted to be brian our lacquer so
[ __ ] bad guys my number's 54 since
fifth grade i have been 54 my whole
[ __ ] life except one year that made
me 90 because right you're fat
and second string you get whatever
[ __ ] number you're getting and
um that's how that went down dude um let
me let this join up
real quick i haven't smoked a bowl i
haven't done
anything nothing whatsoever i've been
smoked ever since yesterday
i know some people you addict but it's
just what i do in the morning i smoke
bowl
today i was so [ __ ] busy i said oh no
my grandma and grandpa were here did i
tell you
my grandma and grandpa came to i sold
the car to my dad but my grandma grandpa
are going to mexico
so my dad dropped him off here because
he's a truck driver and he got a load
in san diego and they picked up the car
cleaned it out had to make sure there
was no weed in there because they're
going to mexico
could you imagine if my grandma grandpa
got pulled over because i forgot some
nugs in the car
i would i would need a time machine
that's all i got to say dude it was very
odd though man my grandma grandpa truck
drivers for 60 years
60 plus years i think and they haven't
been in a diesel
since they retired five years ago and
they rode in my dad's diesel and i asked
my grandma
how was it being in a truck oh no no she
did not she wasn't down because it was
like a prisoner going back to hang out
yourself
exactly my family all they do is they
all own trucking truck uh
semis that's what they do that's what
that's why i've been working my whole
[ __ ] life
because they're hardworking as people
and uh
i just remember seeing my grandma
grandpa this morning when i gave him the
car
and i realized man they are getting old
my grandpa's 88 still drives still works
he's starting to get old i know you're
saying starting my grandpa looks 60.
he's a hard-working ass he used to be a
[ __ ] right-hand man of the devil man
i swear to god there's something evil in
that man when he was younger there was a
demon in there
anyway he's nice now he hopped in the
car uh the mercedes i picked him up
and he looked at me and goes it's a very
nice car
oh thanks grandma goes no no no it's a
very nice car i like the inside
oh yeah i rob you yeah no i don't know
dude
i don't know but i remember thinking my
grandpa's never said more than like 10
words to me unless he's lecturing me
about how to spend money
and he just said nice car and then got
out of it
first time in my life my grandpa's ever
said something nice and that's it
ever he's not he's not an [ __ ] to me
but he used to be piece of [ __ ]
he used to be really mean to everybody
and he got older and realized
yo if i die no one's gonna give a [ __ ]
so he started being real nice and now
he's cool
my grandpa's a cool man he's just it's
been through a lot
[Music]
but yeah sorry i got off on that talk i
wanted to talk about some sports talk
guys i wanted to bring up some [ __ ]
speaking of my dad
marty did you play sports when you're
younger besides basketball yeah i played
all every sport in the street but mainly
just basketball for school school
yeah so i want to tell you guys a little
story since we're on this football topic
right now i know we just went to my
grandma topic and my grandpa being the
devil
but let's get on this football topic
real quick
i just need to talk to you guys about
this i played sports my whole [ __ ]
life
my whole life because you ready i played
soccer
i played soccer five to like eight
i was really good at soccer but i was
bored because it's like yo
this is kind of boring just sprinting
and scoring goal like it's
fun but after a while you're like yo
what am i what else is there to do this
sucks that midfielder is so boring bro i
was a power forward my fat [ __ ] kid i
was a fat kid and that was
a monster i scored eight goals in one
game and my coach took me out of the
game and i almost cried i was like seven
and then my mom had to explain to me and
the coach
after the game because i was just you
know those little kids
were they're crying but they're pissed
that was me bro i scored eight no seven
goals in one [ __ ] game my coach took
me out
and him and my mom had to talk to me and
say those other kids are going to get
really sad if they keep if you keep
scoring on them these are kids you're a
kid
we got to do it for the feelings and i
remember thinking i agree
but i also want to say [ __ ] you because
i want to keep scoring
what's wrong with you so that was my
first experience with sports
and then what happened guys a moment
that changed my life
forever i watched the water boy adam
sandler's my favorite person on the
planet if you know me you know that's a
that's a fact i've been waiting to say i
am 31 years old
since i was seven and i just got to say
this year i just turned 31
and what happened mario text you could
you make me uh put my face on that i'm
saying
when he says that's the first thing when
i woke up on my birthday go
hey can you make me a picture man that's
all i wanted
that's all i wanted was a picture of me
as adam sandler so um
what happened watched waterboy and as a
kid uh like i've
i've got used to get picked on as a kid
a lot so when i see other people get
picked on i would you know i relate to
them i was seven or eight at the time
i relate to that and then i just
remember everybody picking on the water
boy everybody picking on
i look at my mom like this is not fun
why is adam sandler getting [ __ ] with
like this and why is he kind of slow
that's all i remember thinking like why
are they picking on the slow guy
and he opened up a can of whoop ass as
you know
on them and that was it guys i looked at
and go i want to play
whatever the [ __ ] position he's playing
so my mom took me out mid-season of
soccer that's the only year we sucked
we [ __ ] won no games took me out
mid-season to soccer and as i tell my
coach that i'm not playing anymore tall
super tall white guy brown here he looks
at me goes
are you sure you want to quit man cause
we we could use your help i know
we sucked bad there was two good kids me
and some other kid and he looked at me
like
well i might quit too because we're not
gonna win [ __ ] and i quit that day
signed up for football and realized oh
this isn't soccer
there's a lot of running in soccer this
is harder this is so i got my ass
whooped that first year guys i mean i
got [ __ ] up
and i asked them what position do they
play water boy the linebacker
you're also [ __ ] fat you're not
playing linebacker and i was second
string [ __ ] defensive end or
defensive tackle not even defensive end
and that was my whole first year
football so the reason i'm bringing this
up because
i ended up quitting football me and a
coach had an altercation
in the ninth the tenth grade we had
altercation i started uh
center started nose tackle kickoff
return quick
kick off punt pump return [ __ ] like that
i never left the field
but that's what you want when you're a
kid you you want to crack [ __ ]
that's all you want to do i play
football let me [ __ ] hit somebody
so um we're playing playing high school
at the
end of my ninth grade year this is the
story i want to tell you because it
full circle get the [ __ ] out of here so
ninth grade year guys we're undefeated
oh no we yeah we're undefeated at the
time
if you play sports you can relate you
know people watch tape
film for the next team to study and all
that we didn't do that we're from merced
the everybody's on [ __ ] meth but the
kids at school [ __ ] [ __ ] that even the
kids at school are met
everybody's on drugs everybody's doing
something else or they're [ __ ]
pregnant
so nobody watches film
we don't have a tv to roll around
it doesn't happen man you guys didn't
have screens on your on your bus that
you rode to the gym
on your bus we took a school bus
oh okay marty did you have a bus
with a screen [ __ ] oh oh man i thought
you were [ __ ] serious like marty i
thought you grew up in the ghetto would
you talk about the screen
okay um so we
studied tape on the last game of the
year and i remember the coach says you
got to be here before school and i
thought
i don't know if i'm ever gonna play
football anymore because i am not
getting up before
school i'm asleep i live across the
street from high school i live across
the street from my school
school started at 805 i woke up at 7 50.
put my clothes on the left that's the
that's what the [ __ ] i was doing i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm tired so uh i get to school
pissed we watch tape and i'm looking
around like
we're just watching a bunch of little
[ __ ] kids you guys taped secretly
this isn't fun this is kind of weird i
don't like it and they kept talking
about their quarterback
this kid's good he's 6-1 he's running
this on a [ __ ] 40-yard sprint and i'm
i'm in the background you know we're
talking [ __ ] everybody talks [ __ ] when
their coaches aren't paying attention
that's what happens
we're there we're doing the [ __ ]
practice or whatever [ __ ] all week
you know school we're doing [ __ ]
school you go play
after school and then here comes game
day here comes [ __ ] game day guys and
i'm hyped
i'm ready i'm ready to go we're [ __ ]
doing hitting drills which you should i
don't know why why you gotta do hitting
drills work
before you hit [ __ ] stupid
hey warm up you know give yourself a
headache and then go out there
that's exactly what that means it's like
cutting weight before a fight i had to
i had to all the time dude before i got
into high school it was a city league
and like i said i was [ __ ] fat i
never played peewee in fifth grade i was
jv fifth grade i was with the eighth
graders because i was so heavy
and i got my ass whooped um so we're at
the game
everything's going great we're starting
up and you know when you're when
you right now everybody that's ever
played girl or guy everyone's ever
played sports when you're waiting
and you're looking at your opponent
you're just sitting there like
whack ass shoes whack ass haircut [ __ ]
your face
your eyes are lame stupid you're just
trying to talk [ __ ] internally like
i'm gonna [ __ ] your day we all do it
even if you're a nice like me we all do
it
and um i see the kid it's just a bunch
of dudes a bunch of dudes and then
there's the guy they're talking about
[ __ ] me i mean
the kid had like 20 year old definition
to his body like he had
pads i'm looking like no that's a
college student
no no he's not in ninth grade [ __ ]
anyway
game's going on everything's going i've
never gotten a sack in all five years of
playing football
i've never gotten a sack i mean i swim
move spin i'm in
i'm in the backfield every [ __ ] play
i can't remember what time someone had
stopped me from getting in the backfield
never got a sack
i was so slow i wasn't slow these
[ __ ] were so fast
that as soon as i put pressure they'd
run the other side and that person get
the tackle
quarterback come this way they'd run the
other side what up you'd run the other
side and everybody to get the tackle
except for me and never got [ __ ] so here
we are guys
it's like two and a half minutes left in
the game we're up by three we're up by
three and they got the ball we gotta
stop and we win
guys i i got in the backfield and this
motherfucker's throwing the ball
he's not looking at me i'm about to
blindside him and i mean
i'm about to play i was in ninth grade i
was benching three something i was a
little [ __ ] tank
and i'm thinking oh my god i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm shaking around
i'm gonna crack this [ __ ] in
front of everybody we're gonna win the
game he might fumble and it's the star
player that everybody's talking [ __ ]
about
dude i went and with everything i had i
mean i hit him blindside he's not even
looking
i hit him with everything i have and he
just does the nfl
hip toss you know the really good
quarterbacks when they almost get
wrapped up they do like the
twist toss and step he did that [ __ ] to
me
like that he wasn't looking at me he
sensed me
i don't know what the [ __ ] he did but he
sensed
my presence or something and when i hit
him
he spun and i just did this i hit him
and i just flew
i off my feet flew and i can remember
holding his jersey
and then it's slipping out and just ah
and i [ __ ] flew hit the ground
by the time i was getting up this
[ __ ] kid was running
all the way like a 80-something yard
[ __ ] quarterback carry
all the way touchdown we got the ball
back no time lost
we lost the last game of the year
because i missed the sack
and as we're at the sideline the second
string [ __ ] why is it always the
second third string full talking [ __ ] i
have no idea
but they're like well [ __ ] well you
can't make a tackle you're over there
benching you can't even hold on to them
like yo you're not even in the game so
let's just
keep it at that that i try my best i'm
stronger than you
so i'm pretty sure i did i would have
done better than you did you know i'm
trying to like
talk my way out without getting pissed
and also in my head internally i'm so
sad because i let us lose
all right i just told you the story
right that's the story i wanted to tell
you
now here's the wild part as
it's three four years later guys it's no
no it's five years later because it's
after it's like
my third year i'm 20. so yeah i was just
about to like be
finishing up my community college right
uh no 21 i'm sorry i was 21 i was just
started drinking legal
legally uh the nfl draft came on my
friend deuce
i'm with my friend deuce and we're
watching the nfl draft i don't watch the
[ __ ] nfl draft why would i watch the
nfl draft i don't [ __ ] know
i started watching it we're just smoking
weed at his apartment
and nfl draft comes on they're talking
you know they always give a backstory to
the really highlighted character like
the highlighted players like this year
he's going to be drafted
number one so they give a little
backstory they might have went to the
town interviewed some people from town
or their family members
you guys know exactly what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about so
i did that i mean i watched that and as
i'm watching it they go
from turlock california and go what and
i look
and turlock is 15 minutes for merced 15
minutes away
so i'm automatically this person is my
year graduation because i'm about to
graduate college
this person's about to go the nfl you
see what i'm saying so i'm like wait
from turlock and they say yeah the
niners are
looking into him and i'm thinking you're
from turlock and the niners might pick
you up
who is this man and i'm looking at him
and they start saying his name all you
know they're talking about him i'm
looking like
i know you i you look familiar
i know your [ __ ] face
and they call up the name and the niners
pick colin kaepernick
and they call him i'm like yo that's
cool he's from turlock and he's a niners
quarterback he's probably a niners fan
he grew up around here
this is the ultimate kid's dream you
know i was really into football but i
quit and that was i was watching my
dream happen like oh you went to the nfl
you're from the [ __ ] central valley
[ __ ] yeah so i'm all hyped and i'm
looking like
yo i know your [ __ ] face and they say
it's high school pittman
and when they say pitman i realize
that's a [ __ ] kid from the game i
know i know that's the kid from the
[ __ ] game
that i almost sacked that beat us i know
it is
called this dude i know vince call him
like you watch the giraffe he goes yeah
you see colin kaepernick
is that the guy from that we played
against goes bro that's the guy that
everybody
made fun of you because you missed the
sack that's the guy from pitman he just
got drafted
and then all the years of shame just
drifted away guys
because i thought oh he's an nfl
quarterback
of course i've missed the sack of course
he threw my stupid ass
and that was it guys five years of shame
brought to an end because i realized
oh you're calling okay now i don't feel
bad
so that's it guys i [ __ ] missed the
seconds colin kaepernick the
only sack i ever almost got and i swear
i hit him with everything i had
no he's a monster there's a reason
there's a reason he got drafted and went
to the super bowl
there's a [ __ ] reason dude and that's
my colin kaepernick story i thought it
was really funny
we're from the same area i'm over here
smoking weed on the internet and doing
fun [ __ ] and he's oh that's him that's
the picture
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that's the kid man
that [ __ ] looked like sidesies
he kind of does he really does look like
he kind of does look guys there's he's
so when i saw him i was the first thing
i thought to make fun of him and yeah
dude
uh i mean obviously i'm not gonna make
fun of him he's a nice person he's
actually doing some cool [ __ ] but you
know when you're in ninth grade and he's
the opposing team we're gonna talk [ __ ]
yeah that's him from turlock man that
[ __ ]
chucked me he threw me like it wasn't
[ __ ] just his reflexes yeah he's not
even big in that big shirt
and that's that's the picture that's him
i must have been tiny
that's the version of him that bounced
you off him bro he's not even that
defiant well then because he was a man
he was like he's like 11 years old
he might be but he was a grown [ __ ]
man in high school that's all i know
dude he had a [ __ ]
he had a stubble i bet that's that's the
kind of girl man i'm talking about
oh man but yeah uh that's the sports
sports section
sports yeah you're not gonna do too much
sports on this show guys
i like sports i don't really give a [ __ ]
anymore after brett favre dissed me
i don't care you were talking about that
i'm sorry to interrupt but i just have
to like
it reminded me of this story from high
school that was one of the funniest
things and you were talking about you
guys talking [ __ ] in the locker room and
stuff before the game
my uncle was the coach of my high school
team and he was like the oldest whitest
like dude that you could possibly
imagine but he lived and breathed high
school basketball
high school basketball that was his
thing he was a college coach too
oh okay okay we were [ __ ] around in
this little
in our care package somebody wrote on
our board
something to the effect of uh you know
like
billy billy's sister likes black blah
blah blah on the board but he wrote it
in permanent sharpie
thinking it was dry erase all
on the x's and o's board in the game
plan room
and then we all realized it was sharpie
moments before my uncle walked in
so did he did he fight you guys so he
walked my uncle walked in
looked at the board everybody just
like started dying laughing trying to
hold it back he was pissed
he was just disgusted with us he's just
you guys
i remember he's like i thought you guys
were good guys
you guys that's such a disappointing
thing to hear i thought you guys were
good guys that's that's worse than
you owe me money yeah it's like oh damn
i disappoint it's like hurting your
grandma's feeling like that's really
what it was i was like oh
your dad's brother your mom's brother my
dad's
sister's husband oh uncle like that got
you got you
that sucks he's known you said you're a
kid yeah now he's looking at you like
your little [ __ ] pervert one of these
kids it was a room you got a room full
of 14 year olds i mean
but that that [ __ ] was mortifying and
hilarious at the same time
[ __ ] like that's funny man i don't that
shit's [ __ ] funny to me
all the [ __ ] in school was fun yeah i
mean except for school
i hated that [ __ ] um
sorry so guys i want to bring something
up
this is a little segment we're going to
be calling dope d of the day
if we find some really cool i mean
just good people good [ __ ] good stories
that you want to talk about
this is what is this what exactly was
for dope dope d of the day
we got something for you and i think
this is a great way to introduce this
segment
how [ __ ] cool is this guy there it is
college student
so you guys know last week when um the
whole i don't understand stock market
all i know is a bunch of [ __ ]
poor fools got some money last week so a
bunch of people put in on stocks as you
know
and wanna got a damn one made a bunch of
money on the stock market from gamestop
so this kid uh his name is what hunter
what is it
hunter khan yes hunter khan 21 year old
student from cornell
this is uh he's from minnesota this
[ __ ]
uh made 50 million or 50 000
off the stocks right off the gamestop
stocks
so instead of spending it on a [ __ ]
car
or a bunch of white claws like another
21 year old would
this guy went and bought 30 racks 30 000
worth of nintendo switches like you know
the games that you
you know a switch like a psp and donated
every one of them to the children's
hospital for all these kids that are
bored
as [ __ ] in the ch first off they're in
the hospital
second it's covered they can't even have
[ __ ] visitors
and third it must be so damn boring and
you can't even talk or get close to the
kid next to you to make conversation
30k worth of nintendo switches what
about you found his instagram
you're a monster i love you marty you're
[ __ ] great
he got 32 000 likes on his last picture
and he only has four posts on his
account
there you go man because he's a badass
30 30
000 worth of nintendo switches and game
to all the kids that is the dope d
to the day that is [ __ ] badass hunter
you're the man you're awesome if you
happen to watch this
if you happen to ever come across this
or one of your friends let you know
send us an email send us a contact and
let me shoot you some push tree [ __ ]
because that is badass i've who else
who else does [ __ ] like this hunter
you're the man i would like to think
that i would have did some [ __ ] like
that
at that that is so desperate you got
50 and you gave away 30.
come on that i'm gonna be honest i would
have done that
100 maybe 10. you want to i have five
things you want me to give you three
i don't know about that one man i don't
know dude but back then i was selling
anything i would have just bought more
packs
and made money well then again maybe i
would have done i don't know
uh it's so sad i think how much money i
spent on frivolous that [ __ ] in my 20s
man
it's all bad um so guys
today if you're here and you're hanging
out
and you want to hear something wild i
got something for you i do this thing
called story time on youtube uh check it
out
dopaziola on youtube that is my account
i do something called story time we're
in season three right now this is a
third year telling stories
this started off with my iphone 5 6.
i just filmed i i told my girlfriend one
day you know what i think i'm gonna
record myself talking about
the first time i ever sold a sack the
first time i ever saw weeds [ __ ]
it was a fluke i was scared the whole
time and then a spark went off in my
head and
that is the last day that i didn't sell
weed until
i started doing all this dope as yolo
stuff so this guy's
is um from story time i've done so many
topics
almost dying of getting shot at almost
killing people
randomly car accidents random [ __ ] this
one i want to talk to you guys about and
i saw my grandma this morning so it kind
of makes it a little funny so
i want to tell you guys about a little a
little drug i used to love
i mean me and this fool were friends we
hung out
daily i'm talking about cocaine i
love coke so much not now i mean no
take that back i love coke right now as
you're listening to this i love
it i won't do it i haven't done it in
nine years going on 10 because i'm
[ __ ] fat
and chris farley is one of my favorite
people and if he would have just stopped
the drugs he would still be making me
laugh
right now so that's why i do not take
the chance because other [ __ ]
like to laugh at the [ __ ] i do
and i don't want him to go why'd you
have to do that what the [ __ ]
i don't want that that's why i do not do
drugs anymore that's the only reason
because i [ __ ] love coke you think i
don't want to do a half gram
just a rail across the table while the
podcast is going of course i do
i just can't i just can't my heart my
heart my heart is telling me no
you see what i'm saying about my body
all right back to the cocaine so guys i
started doing coke when i was probably
14 14 or 15 i don't know whenever i hang
out with joe and anthony well let's just
say going on 15.
i started doing cocaine and before that
i would only smoke weed
and drink i never did any other drugs i
didn't do [ __ ]
so here we go let's talk about cocaine
um uh let's say if you did coke and
you guys are probably doing coke right
now just a minute if you're in the
garage
chopping one up you probably have a
keystone light next to you
just gonna i'm being real because that's
what the [ __ ] was next to me in ryan's
garage
keystone light cocaine the [ __ ]
sweats and cigarettes it's all
that's all we have you're picking a
picture right now
and a ping pong table that later broke
and just stayed in the side of the
garage for years
um so this is the story of the first
time i ever bought coke by myself
and went and did it alone you know when
you're a kid
you do drugs for the first time new
drugs with oh with other people
right unless you're a baller and you're
like you know what today i want to try
acid and just go get it
then you're [ __ ] awesome and you're
the kid from american beauty and that's
a whole different story
so the first time i mean i was always
doing coco my homies i've never
personally chopped up the lines
and remember i'm from merced there's no
way it was all coke
i can i can smell bad coke to this day
i can look at it smell and go that is
cut that [ __ ] is
not cocaine when i move to l.a i know a
little off topic when i move to l.a and
some
i don't do coke like i said some of my
friends do
i've never seen bricks of coke before
and i've never seen fish scale coke
where it
shines like snow have you ever seen you
know when
you know when snow shines marty from the
sun and it looks wet
yeah it's amazing yo i've seen i saw no
i won't say when
i saw a brick like that oh my god it was
the
it was so pretty i'm gonna say that real
cocaine stinks
i mean it smells you could taste that
[ __ ]
so if everybody just got that drip
feeling in their mouth i just did too
don't worry you're not alone i just did
too i loved that [ __ ] anyway
before you think i'm just a drug addict
over here i'm just smoking a joint we're
hanging out so let's just talk about
past drug [ __ ]
here we go first time i ever bought it
myself i never chopped it up
and when we did we would just you know
pour out your gram get a dollar bill or
some paper
put it over it and then get a card
credit card and start like
flattening it out like trying to chop it
through the paper or the dollar
because if not when it's rock car
cooking
30 bucks 20 bucks 30 bucks just shoots
off little rocks will just
it's like trying to pop a pez with your
finger on a table
pieces are going to fly you see what i'm
saying like it's not going to stay
contained
and everybody driving right now my bad
my mother i know you're going to work
i'm over here making you salivate over
the times you did cocaine because
it was [ __ ] delicious um
so yeah i've never done it before i've
watched my friends do it
this time this dude gabe i went well
8th street went to 8th street bought a
dub off of my dub
for everybody out there that's goes to
the dispensary only to buy weed that dub
is 20
with a weed all right so dub um
is this much that's it's that much coke
all right it's like four lines to your
face that's it and lines can vary
one can be john it doesn't matter i got
skimped let's say that i did not get my
full money's worth
because he knew my sister and my sister
was you guys know from last time we
talked my sister was a dick to me
and it was her friend so she if he knew
let's just put it this way i was getting
skimped
all right she was probably telling don't
give them everything you give it and
just give it to me or just keep it we'll
do it together i was a little brother
so uh did you bringing up fish scale
cocaine right now are we getting
kicked off youtube don't put this on the
screen we're gonna get
oh that [ __ ] looks bomb i'm just gonna
say that
from here it's got a d e a watermark on
it
like it's their ignition that's crack on
the right
for sure that's not cocaine bro the one
with the
that was crap anyway um
i'll tell you guys later by the time i
smoke crack my uncle john here we go so
i get the sack for myself go to my
grandma grace's my grandma
if you guys don't know i've had i don't
even know talked about it yet she lives
in the country for merced it's all
residential there's some there's a nice
part and there's the [ __ ] ghetto
and there's the rest of it where all the
meth heads are on the outside there's
some
nice ass houses where like the white
girls and
white dudes in high school get jeeps for
their 16th birthday
those style houses you know there's not
a lot of white people in my town but the
ones that are
you're either that kid or you're smoking
meth with your parents
there's no in between there's no [ __ ]
in between i spy
maybe not now but when i was growing up
there's no in between you're either rich
or you're [ __ ] white trash poor
like the rest of us except we're mexican
and uh
my grandma's rich all right my grandma
grandpa the truck drivers are [ __ ]
dumb ass rich because they work and they
invest all their money in property so
they
they got care package coming in all of
you guys hear that but we got one coming
in
and um they live in the outskirts of
town
so they live in a farm farmhouse there's
like three acres of land around their
house you know what i'm saying and it
comes to their house
so i would go over there on the weekends
because it was my dad's weekend for
split custody and my dad was on drugs
so he wasn't there and i just chilled my
grandma's it was a time to get away from
my mom because at the time my mom was
being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and for everybody out there you'll learn
more about my mom at the time
we were not we're not on the same level
all right we weren't we weren't chest
bumping
we weren't fist bumping either we were
just mad so uh mom's being a [ __ ]
so it was my time to go to my grandma's
and i was there and my grandma and
grandpa are hard ass workers they go to
bed at eight
o'clock at night every night [ __ ] 60
years and they wake up at 4 30 or 5 and
get in their trucks the diesels and go
work
for 12 hours right
so i know from 8 o'clock at night till 4
in the morning
i got a bunch of room time buy myself
cocaine and cigarettes that's all i
cared i had a dub i had a pack
of of camel wides no no
camel non-filters and then i started
smoking whites later i smoked
non-filters because my uncle john did
and it's safe to assume that weeds all
mixed into this or were you know we
worried about
if i cook there's no wheat yeah if i
cook there's no weed at all
uh because i had no money so i'd be
working like i got 30 bucks
i'm deaf if i was by myself yeah there
was no weed
um so
at my grandma's there's no system called
the internet
there's no er there's no life it's just
us and the cuts surrounded by yellow
grass and diesels
so there's me
got my cocaine telling my grandma it's
like 7 30. i'm like oh
i'm kind of tired i think i was gonna
watch a movie i'm playing the part you
know
at the time i was just got i was just
got done being a 4.0 student
[ __ ] four years straight they had a
party my grandma and dad had a party for
me because i won
math student of the year and i got 4.0
two years in a row
but if you guys know my mom was paying
me one day she's like if you get
straight a's i'll pay you so i got
straight a's for two years
that's a different story but uh so i'm
playing the part i'm like alright
grandma good night guys
[Music]
so i went to my uh the middle room it's
a long hallway so there's about
25 feet between my grandma's room and
the room i'm in
and there's there's one way uh there's
one door and there's a sliding glass
door so my sliding glass do i close it i
open it close it go to the side of the
house smoke [ __ ] cigarette
i literally check where the wind is
blowing so i know which way is not gonna
blow toward their
their room or their window because they
sleep with their window open and i smoke
my cigarettes
do my little line smoke some more
cigarettes and then
that's it that's my that was my whole
[ __ ] plan
my grandma has no internet there's no
such thing as a
entertainment out there so i brought the
movies that i had because there's only
speed and cruel intentions on tape
that's it oh no no and bloodsport that's
it's all that there's in that room
there's three tapes and i [ __ ]
know every line to them so
my grandma goes to sleep i wait about 20
minutes and then i just start trying to
chop up my lines i got dave chappelle's
killing him softly
i got eddie murphy delirious eddie
murphy raw
only three movies i had with me that
night because i thought i'm gonna do
lines by myself
for the first time by myself i'll smoke
cigarettes i'ma laugh my [ __ ]
ass off this is going to be a great
night this is going to be great
so it's about 8 20 8 30 i get a dollar
bill start chopping it up
remember i've never done it myself i i
don't know how long you go i know they
make it lines
i know they make it it's powdery i get
that i know
i know that part all right so i'm
chopping it up and after i'm done
it's just not turning into powder
it was winter time guys and the moisture
in the air was making my [ __ ] clump up
if you
didn't cook it it was making my shake
bub there's no heat to rip my grandma's
there's a fireplace on the other side of
the house and that's it so you have five
blankets
that's the heater so the moisture in the
room is a sliding glass door
with one handle missing so there's a
hell of [ __ ] wind coming it was cold
in that room right
so so it clumped up the moisture got it
or some i mean now that i realized it
was more moisture than anything
and uh i said [ __ ] it so i started doing
it i started doing a line i chopped one
up
and as i did it like half of it fell
right out of my nose you guys know what
i'm saying when you do a line
and if some of it just falls out like it
didn't go anywhere that's exactly what
happened
it got too clumped up and didn't go so
i'm sitting there chopping it up
chopping it up chopping it more
and i finally get one and it hurts so
bad
i mean it hurts from my nose behind my
eye to my brain
you guys know that you know when you get
water up your nose forever you have
never
uh for those of you that never done coke
when you get water up your nose under
the pool it's like oh
[ __ ] and it hurts that's the same
feeling when you do bad lines
it's the same feeling that happens so i
got that and it was severe
right behind my [ __ ] eye
and i say i'm gonna go smoke a cigarette
go out and smoke a cigarette
come back in watching raw watching eddie
murphy laughing
and trying to stay quiet so my grandma
doesn't i can hear him coming down the
hallway it's tile my grandma's mexican
[ __ ] tile everywhere so i can hear
her coming down the hallway so i have
some type of you know 10 seconds to
put my [ __ ] away and i already had it to
where i can just put a pillow on top of
it
if she walked in so i had it all i had
it all planned
and um it's about two hours later i'm
like another half a line start splitting
it so i can make my night last
and each little bump i do just i mean it
hurts bad guys
is it hurt i've never felt that pain
before
i'm getting on when i start coming in
like all right i don't know maybe i'm
not chopping it right
so the night's going on the night's
going on i don't realize guys it's like
2 30 in the morning and i'm down to my
last baby baby bump i was doing one like
every 20 30
um like one every 30 40 minutes i was
doing a line or a little bump
so it's about 2 30 in the morning i do
my last one right
so that's it it's all it's all gone
there's no more coat my nose
my nose oh no before my last bump is
gone sorry before my last bump is gone
guys
my left side starts bleeding now you
guys know you guys been there if you do
go
my left side starts bleeding and i used
to have really bad nosebleeds as a kid
i'd go to the doctor and get my [ __ ]
cauterized i ever tell you that i'd get
my nose cauterized the vessel
up top because i just had bad nosebleeds
as a kid so here i am shoving this
[ __ ] bad coke up my nose
and it starts bleeding so what did i do
i got two nostrils
what the [ __ ] i'm gonna use the other
one i tried and it was plugged
that's it it was plugged so i thought i
have one little bump left was a pretty
good size bump
i saved it for like oh my last one it
was a pretty good size bump and i said
i'm gonna just blow my nose clean my
nose out with the blood and i'm gonna do
it up that nostril that's bleeding
because that's the only one that's not
plugged
so here i am 15.
about to be a drug addict it sounds like
it's about like you know you're bleeding
you're still doing it
yes yes and my friend ryan and ethan
they used to fill up
soda bottle caps with water like soda
bottle you know like little caps
and they would snort the water down
their nose and it would push all the
coke that got stuck and you would get a
fat drip
the drip is one of my favorite things i
know people don't like it i [ __ ] love
it it's like drinking a sprite like yeah
i just woke the [ __ ] up
that's how it feels like i'm refreshed
that
i'm not advocating you go do drugs coke
is horrible for you it will kill you
that's why i don't do it
it's like saying yo i love driving 90
miles an hour on a turn
but yeah it's exhilarating yeah but
you're gonna die eventually
not worth it that's coke for me all
right it's fun but you know you're gonna
die
so here we go i started the water bottle
cap i forgot to say that throughout the
night i was snoring
the water to try to like make the drip
she was psychotic i'm sorry go ahead
yeah sorry well this is i'm just trying
to explain and remember all of this is
happening in
10 seconds i'm just explaining to you
where my brain was when
i was doing it and why i was doing those
things so let's start the water bottle
throughout the water bottle cap
throughout the night or whatever
and so it starts bleeding so i clean it
up
and i go to do the bump and just it just
won't stop it's not pouring anymore but
it's like a little
drip you guys know what i'm saying just
like one trail of blood
so i'm wiping it wiping it and i'm
waiting for it to stop and it doesn't so
i just say [ __ ] it
and i hit the bump and i remember it
just like i
tasted blood and coke and i thought that
was [ __ ]
sorry i just grossed myself out oh my
god i'm a [ __ ] gag
i could see you know it's [ __ ] i'm sorry
for everybody driving
i'm sorry i'm sorry paycheck to the road
i'm sorry
um i taste the blood and coke
i don't give a [ __ ] as long as i taste
the coke
so i'm like all right cool i did the
last bump it's like 2
30. and my grandma i can hear her
getting up about oh my god you pulled up
pulp fiction
that's me
oh yeah the single drip of blood like
when chucky nose bleeds remember
oh this doll bleeds remember it has one
rip
yeah i just gave you a visual that's
what it drip like
yeah exactly hey bro stop
i hate chucky so much it's so scary
that's a whole nother story anyway and
then it's just calling cap next face
with a turtle
chucky to call kaepernick holding a
turtle okay guys sorry to get off topic
for every drive here we go
so um i do the do the line anyway it's
about
four o'clock four thirty i can hear my
grandma get up right
and about five i know they leave at five
five fifteen they're always out the
[ __ ] door they got their coffee
they're gone they're out there
they're working and i go out there
hey what's up guys like with my eyes
just like the damn dude i need to be an
actor i just made myself
feel tired sorry
don't forget again for everyone driving
i'm sorry wake up
um i go out there oh hey what's up here
that's not how my grandma talks but i'm
not trying to do a mexican
lady trying to spe she sounds like the
lady from family guy that cleans
that's exactly what my grandma grace
sounds like oh hello my grandma's so
cool man she's so cool
and uh oh you gotta bring a picture of
my grandma or something
don't don't please um
anyway yeah she talks like her and uh
i'm like hell yeah i just woke up i'm
gonna go back to sleep
just saying bye all right guys i'll see
you when you get back off work
and i just
go back in my room lay there i'm just
[ __ ] man my nose and the whole time i
got a headache stinging ass headache
but i'm not on one anymore at all like
all i have left is the bag and i always
just
like flipped inside out and gummed
whatever coke was on there and my mouth
would get them
so that was already gone there's no more
drugs i have no weed
it's about 5 30 ish when they're
fully gone and they're tr i mean the
driveway is long as [ __ ]
so when they're out and i can see them
at the last part right before they hit
the free uh 59
right before the 59 see it and they're
gone
i'm like all right thank god i don't
have to worry no more about being caught
for
i don't have anything anyway like where
my mind was
you pull an all-nighter on coke by
yourself just watching hilarious [ __ ]
your brain is not where it should be
it's a little [ __ ] up it's a little
off i didn't eat
i obviously didn't drink [ __ ] i'd have
no beer i had nothing i was just
on one i made a little dub sack last me
[ __ ] five or six hours
so um they leave
and i'm outside and i smoke a cigarette
right there in front of my
grandmas i think whoa i've never done
this before i've never been up
early enough to where you know because
if they go come home for lunch and if
i'm smoking cigarette
they're in the country they're going to
see a cloud of smoke leaving their house
if you know what my grandma's house
looked like you could see anyone in the
front from a half mile away
because the long-ass driveway and
there's a [ __ ] it's a house so if you
see someone walking you're gonna see
them
you know what i'm saying so i couldn't
be smoking a cigarette and they're
popping up like wow i'm smoking
in front of the house i'm a badass like
oh [ __ ] here we go
and i smoke a cigarette and i go to walk
back in the house i get about
six steps like kill bill remember he
walks and he just falls
that's basically what i did i took like
five steps
and i went ah and something
hit me in my nose to my brain just like
a
uh water boy's mom
that's exactly how i felt but i fell to
my knee
and then i started getting a throb in my
eye and i went to my other d and i just
started holding my [ __ ]
face and i remember i went what the [ __ ]
and i started getting somebody i've
talked about this before and somebody
said you had a little seizure i don't
know if i had a little seizure i don't
know if i did but here we go
i fell to my knee and i got to my other
knee i'm holding my eye i'm holding my
face like yo what the [ __ ] is happening
everyone's gone
there's nobody here in case i start
[ __ ] convulsing
because i thought oh no i did too much
coke
i did you know what i mean i've never
done that much by myself i never dubbed
my face we all put in
uh getting an eight ball between six or
seven of us throughout the whole night
we're drinking and par you know what i
mean that's different than just sitting
[ __ ] feeding it out all night in the
damn middle room and um
i look i remember i looked up and as i
look up i just start
gushing blood off both my nostrils just
start leaking leaking like bad leaking
and i have the headache and i remember
all the taste of cigarettes in my mouth
i'm dehydrated as [ __ ]
imagine this dehydrator [ __ ] on my
[ __ ] knee on the red
grain brick that's in front of my
grandma's house it's 5 30
in the morning the sun is peaking i mean
the sun's just coming over the damn
mountains i remember this
in full the sun's just coming up it's
not all the way up
and you know that early morning sun come
up you think about everything in your
life no matter
what the [ __ ] it is you're like wow
every time i see that i think of the
outsiders when uh when uh
johnny is dead and he's narrating the
stay good point boy and make sure you
watch out
that's how i think of every time
ralph macchio narrating in my head all
i'm on coke
sorry i'm on my knees i look up my nose
is bleeding i'm wiping my face
i get the headache i have no [ __ ]
like saliva in my body
and i look i'm looking up at the sky and
i remember i go this
is not the way this is not how i want my
life to be
everything hurts nothing's positive i
got
nothing to do right now it's 5 30 and
i'm
up what am i go you know what i'm
thinking everything
is done everything in my life is
pointing to dog [ __ ] at that point
and then i come to find out of real
quick i'll skip ahead come to find out
that
the coke that he was selling was cut
with cup of meth
that's why it was hurting so damn bad
and that's why when i was when i was
when i was trying to grind it it was
still shards like it was
there i said it was clumping up for the
moisture it was shards in there i was
like well it's really shiny
but it's not like it's not like the coke
i've seen today that's shiny the fish
scale [ __ ] i can tell the difference now
i was a child i was [ __ ] 15
first sack i ever bought by myself
probably only got a point three out of
that [ __ ]
i don't know anyway i remember
i go in the house and i decide i'm never
just gonna buy a sack and do it by
myself i'm gonna just do sex with my
friends
have to coco my friends other than that
i'm gonna i'm a drug addict i'm just
gonna be a drug addict piece of [ __ ]
and that's the day i kind of just all
right man
you're 15 this is not the way to be and
that's the time i did coke by myself for
the first time
yeah that was the whole the whole story
so marty you're doing coke by yourself
in your grandma's house i've actually
never done coke no no oh you're a
champion i love you
i love me my homie jay's never done coke
either and i love it
it's so sick how cool man they don't
have coke in these ghosts
see me and my friends we had a different
relationship with it if you were doing
coke we looked at you like a [ __ ] oh
your eyes were selling it yeah
there was like a whole different story i
had a different perspective on it but
when i got with
april her and her friends had a
different relationship with it so i had
to because they did cocaine
it was more accepted in those circles so
but for me
if i if you did cocaine i would i would
not like you whoa but you're making
money off those people
yeah but i wouldn't i would have a
disrespect for you
it was just how if they were nice it
didn't matter like her
friends her friends that would do it i
wouldn't like
i would i wouldn't trust him i would be
put off behind them okay okay
because you're over here selling it to
knocks and it was getting me wrapped up
in situations too where these dudes are
doing [ __ ] now ever
you know yeah no i totally understand
wow you've never done coke [ __ ]
congratulations that's so
cool dude keep it that way yeah keep it
that way because it's a part
that whole story you just told is a
goddamn advertisement to not do cocaine
yeah i got about 30
that advertise you the opposite also so
we'll just we'll just say
don't do drugs let's just leave it leave
it at that segment do not do [ __ ]
cocaine if you've never done you've
never had me
leading out of my face on my knees bro
that was the first
round with me doing by myself that
didn't stop me
all i did was go i need to perfect the
chopping
i need to learn how to chop it a little
better and then i found out it was cut
with meth because it was like don't get
that [ __ ] from him over on eighth street
uh she had me up all night like me too i
didn't sleep
the whole day so that was my coke and my
grandma's story
and um yeah so did you sleep after that
no no no i stayed awake i stayed awake
and watched no cable i watched
the same movies i watched over and i did
end up watching speed after that
because i was done with this you can't
watch stand-ups back-to-back you can't
wait for a punch line what
you can't do that's why i gotta wait a
couple years and watch stand-up again
but yeah i watched speed [ __ ] keanu
reeves kept me company for a minute
then i would just wandered around for
[ __ ] hours
being on speed not knowing it yo not
knowing it yeah not knowing it but um
that was fun let's change it up it's
[ __ ] horrible
oh i like this topic this is a segment
that we're introducing
uh it's called what's good and it could
be
let's put it this way it's all the stuff
that we've been watching
listening or suggesting that you guys go
watch
because i know there's a lot of younger
viewers and by younger i mean
i know i look like a little kid but i'm
also born in 89 i am not a child anymore
there's people that i chill and smoke
with i forget like
you're 21. bro i forgot we kind of
almost
the same [ __ ] age and we act to say
you know what i mean there's age doesn't
really mean anything to me so if there's
a 21 year old i'm chilling with
you i was just 21 the other day i'm not
worried about that
so the reason i bring that up is i want
to give suggestions too because i know a
lot of the younger crowd probably hasn't
seen a lot of the [ __ ] i'd know
i know a lot of [ __ ] because my mom my
mom raised me
even though we got into some [ __ ] she
has a
great taste in music and movies so
that's where i got it from and then it
just sprouted from there
so i got to see a lot of good [ __ ] early
you know i was in the classic rock david
bowie and doo-wop [ __ ] only until i was
about 10.
that's all i knew i didn't know
mainstream artists i only knew the dope
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] the credence and
doobie brothers and [ __ ]
that's what i was listening to and i got
made fun of it all the time
at school like you like the beatles the
black and guys in black and white
like you know what [ __ ] you that's all i
remember thinking the first cd i ever
got in my life's sixth birthday was
please please me that's the first
first album i ever got and then i
remember looking through the rest of the
cds and like oh it's the same cover like
10 years later but they're all hit beat
the [ __ ] out
in the same the signal picture i'm
talking about i love that [ __ ] and my
first album first album ever
i got it at stephen no the park next to
golden valley that's where i got it from
if you guys are from merced you know
that park right there um so what's good
here's a segment i want to bring up some
stuff guys and i'm going to suggest you
guys go watch this
and no it's not today's sponsor is
brought to you by [ __ ]
netflix no that's not what we're doing i
want to suggest this because i'm
shocked on how good this [ __ ] movie
was so rosie and i we've been seeing
billboards
and uh [ __ ] on my phone for that movie
it's a pixar movie guys
a [ __ ] pixar movie you guys got you
guys are listening to right now all
right that's how good this damn movie
was
i watched the movie pixar with rosie my
girlfriend we watched the movie soul
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't suggest you
watch with your kids because
they might be [ __ ] bored wow
i loved it so [ __ ] much i'm comparing
it
in the way i love it like the way i love
what dreams may come with robin williams
the way it's so
[ __ ] deep and
all-ending you know what i'm saying if
you've never seen that movie spoiler
that movie's been out for 50 [ __ ]
years
um dreamworld dreams may come robin
williams dies and goes his own heaven
and it's more like a pick and choose i'm
not going to spoil it for you go watch
that [ __ ] movie it's really sad
though
so be prepared it's robin williams
crying
there's not many things sadder than that
i don't know man every time
he he's one of the people that always
his smiles looked like his cries so you
weren't sure if he was going to smile or
cry when he did
you're like yo i don't want to see robin
williams cry at all man this is sad
see you just want to see him like that
happy um
soul was [ __ ] great i am shocked i
this kids might be
a little bored with it but the
animation's cool wow what a [ __ ]
message in that movie what
a well thought out movie and for them to
bring that to pixar they could have did
a
they could have did a dramatic
oscar-winning
[ __ ] real life movie with that and
they went pixar
i love it man i really suggest you guys
go watch that [ __ ] it's one of the
better movies i've seen in a minute and
i'm
that says a lot because i [ __ ] watch
a lot of movies this is a great
mario if you watch this movie no my kids
have but
they probably thought it was cool you're
going to think of it have you dana have
you seen it
oh my god it was so is the idea that
it's explaining death to kids or is that
no no no no no
it's it's more of an adventure for the
kids but when you're looking at it
and just take a step back it's
it's good it's really [ __ ] good man a
lot of times
like i said these are some of my
favorite movies like avatar up
even like the most never seen up we
almost watched the other night and i
went so it's a guy just floating around
she goes yeah
let's just let's watch something else
and then we watched my next
my next part of what's good segment
something i suggest you don't watch
because i am upset rosie's smiling at me
i watched ocean's 11. i know it's been
30 [ __ ] years since this came out i
watched ocean's 11 the other day
very unimpressed it was pretty cool kept
me entertained
but who the [ __ ] is directing these
movies and they go yo
i know we have two more scenes you know
to tie it up let's just stop
like you know what i'm done all right
we're done
that's how the [ __ ] these movies end i
watched ocean's 12 last night because i
had to give it a chance
and these [ __ ] ended it like
sopranos
mid [ __ ] sentence i thought some [ __ ]
was gonna happen would they explain it
but no
all they did was pay all the money
the [ __ ] so now everybody's broke
i don't like this movie they push 12.
bro no that was [ __ ] 15 years ago
that's 15 years ago the thing that kept
me entertained
was like uh george clooney's
attitude like it wasn't dust till dawn
and i thought he might pull some crazy
[ __ ] i like this
other than that i'm not a big george
clooney fan i haven't really seen a lot
of his movies
but the ones i have seen is [ __ ]
awesome uh young brad pitt as
fight club kept me entertained the only
reason i said yes
because we went on it you never seen it
rosie said that
and i went i'm good and then it said
bernie mac i went are you [ __ ]
kidding me put that [ __ ] on
i know bernie mac was in ocean's eleven
let's watch both of them
and um he was the only good part about
the movies bernie mac's great and he
wasn't even trying to be funny and it
was still funny
and that was it his voice is just funny
he's just it's
it's his it's everything man it's
everything about it it's like a
it's like frank sinatra it's like oh
frank sinatra is a really good singer
yeah yeah
but outside of singing he's kind of the
man
you know like it's it's kind of at the
point where it's he's so cool and
everything you kind of just gotta go
oh no he's just cool you can't say
anything bad
you can't say i mean you know you can he
was
let's just not say anything bad about
strength how about that we just leave it
that
same with bernie mac don't talk [ __ ]
[ __ ] was hilarious he was
hysterical
finished the bernie mac show again and
even that got abruptly stopped and i was
sad
after season five it was it they just
kind of wrapped it up weird i was so sad
that it ended
i had to look it up he was getting sick
so they kind of just stopped and the
ratings weren't as high but
oh my god i love brady mac so [ __ ]
much um
so yeah that's the that's what's good
that's what's good
um oh real quick let me suggest for
everyone that made
if you're not a big movie person and or
you're probably younger
let me suggest a movie to you go watch
what dreams may come
but also do me a favor if you like robin
williams the movie i've been watching
since i was a kid
dirty 30 and i see 31 30. all these ages
and all these movies i always thought
what am i going to be doing when i'm 30.
definitely do you think i'll be getting
high as [ __ ] um go watch the world
according to garp
that's another robin williams movie john
lithgow's in it real young
one of my favorite movies of all time it
is so
[ __ ] good and i feel like i ask
people have you ever seen this
nobody almost nobody i've ever met has
seen this [ __ ] movie it's
marty you seen this definitely not oh
bro
john lithgow plays a girl it's so good
john lithgow's the the dad from third
rock from the sun
oh god he plays a chick he looks like
he's he's amazing man
oh he kind of does like bruce jenner
you're right
marty you're right they do resemble each
other
dude what a [ __ ] movie anyway that's
what's good world according to garp
um what dreams may come to randomly but
two rob williams movies
go watch those movies all right this is
my suggestions marty
you got to watch them too if you got
some time both these movies are so
[ __ ] good you got to watch them man
they're i'm dying classics fan morgan
mindy
ladies all that classics bro um
[Music]
i think uh i think we're gonna close
this out guys
uh we're a little hit a little over an
hour we got some guests coming up
if this oh yeah this is the episode
three so this is
we're filming prior so i'm trying not to
talk out of dates but yes
this is episode three thank you guys so
much for watching next week's video
that's what i should be saying since
it's episode three
episode four we will have another guest
guys i'm really excited we're trying to
dial everything in
we've been working on this for a while
we're trying to dial in the angles how
oh you know what let's switch this up
well let's try this let's try this
so for visually if you're on youtube or
you're on dopaziola.com that's where
this is hosted
dopaziol.com click podcast if you're
watching that
on there let us know if you want if you
have some suggestions you think would be
cool
[ __ ] drop it in the comments if you're
on youtube drop in the comments guys we
are
all we're not like [ __ ] you we know what
we're doing we do know what we're doing
but we're not
we don't know everything in the planet
and there's some input that might help
[ __ ] great man
if you do this it all we're saying is
we're not prudes all right if you ever
have some suggestions or stuff or
even guests you want to see drop that
[ __ ] in the comments guys me and marty
are open to that [ __ ]
my goal is to always keep the show you
know what you guys want to see
yeah what do you guys want to see that's
the main goal it's not i don't like that
no we want it we want to entertain you
guys and i just want to talk to some
interesting
interesting
people that's really the point of this
podcast man is to talk to some
interesting
people different takes on you know what
i mean so let us know we're not [ __ ]
so you can always comment we'll always
talk to you guys
never never think we're too [ __ ] cool
to not comment back because we
we will hit us up on instagram the dope
as usual podcast
there's underscores in between our
youtube is the dope as usual podcast
underscores in between
uh the links are in the description on
this website and if you're youtube the
links are below on the web um
in the description of the video also so
guys
thank you so much we're hitting a little
over an hour if you are on your way to
work
thank you so much for making us part of
your day i really [ __ ] appreciate
that because when i'm driving taking
trips
i feel like i'm getting to know these
people like friends that's how that's
why i
love podcasts you can really tell i
would like to hang out with this person
just by the way that they're talking so
i really love podcasts so if you guys
are choosing to take your time
spend your time because i know your time
is valuable so if you're taking the time
to
listen to us on your way to work and let
us be your mood on the way to work
i [ __ ] appreciate that guys that's a
that's a huge commitment on your part
thank you so much for letting us be part
of your day if you're at home chilling
smoking hanging out with your friends
thank you for letting us be part of the
smoke the circle if you're not smoking
that's different i'm just saying because
we smoke a lot of wheat over here so if
you're just chilling with your friends
listening or you're just by yourself in
your room you're by yourself in your
office
thank you thank you for making this part
of your day and um
we just did a video on this but i know
it's a hard time everyone's
having a hard time financially
everyone's having a hard time socially
it's gonna pass guys i understand it
seems like forever i can't believe it's
been a year
it's been a year almost since i've been
[ __ ] in my house
and it's so weird time's flying by it
doesn't it
it doesn't not affect everyone it
affects every single [ __ ] person it
might be different
so if you're at home and you're stressed
you're sad and this is helping you
i'm so [ __ ] stoked to hear that that
is
the you know what i'm saying like cool
oh yeah we're getting views oh cool
but people come up to you or people dm
us and say oh you really [ __ ]
i was going through some [ __ ] my
girlfriend broke up i have [ __ ]
anxiety and you guys really
you guys help me that is the coolest
thing that we could
ever ask for so don't be shy if you're
in the dms or you're in the comments or
anything like that
dude we will take the time and i'm not
saying we can get to everybody
but we do take the time to talk so if
you guys have thoughts like that you
guys have stuff like that
feel free to talk to us hit us in the
comments um maybe we'll cover it on the
next you never know
people are going through the same [ __ ]
at home you're not alone i will tell you
that no matter what you're going through
i guarantee you're not alone
so for everyone just making this part of
your day thank you for letting us
try to entertain you try to cheer you up
a little bit guys thank you so much
marty
i appreciate you likewise you're the man
thank you so much guys
so this has been the dope as usual
podcast episode three and i know when we
get later
episodes i'm gonna be high as [ __ ] and
i'm gonna forget to say what episode it
is but
this is episode three alright guys this
is uh dope as usual podcast episode
three i am your host doe faziola thank
you guys so much for hanging out with us
have a dope ass day
i barely smoked this joint i was so
stuck in that coke story
i was lost
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]